hi hey well it's good to see both y'all
first of all this film is so
funny the nukavi buck
done it was the music for me you guys
are hilarious thanks um who breaks
character the most
neither one of us yeah i was about to
say we both do reg don't break uh
i think we always just want to try to
save the take you know what i mean if
somebody breaks that means we can't use
it no more so we just try to keep it
moving we laugh after though we laugh
after yeah yeah it seemed like it was a
lot of fun to make is this one of those
films that you just
just truly enjoy through and through
making i enjoyed plus i loved it
it wasn't all fun it was a lot of work
in that film but yeah i
i cannot imagine making it with someone
else but sterling like he made the work
part fun
so like the it was so it was all fun
but it was even more fun to get in the
van and be like damn we just did nine
pages
oh my goodness something about a pastor
in prada it gives you chills yes it does
out of the two of you who is more into
fashion who is more high maintenance
about fashion you know this is going to
sound interesting because i'm fairly low
maintenance but i think i might be yeah
slightly high reg will come to work
reg come to work you like is that
virginia
or a little homeless boy
it's
but then you know sterling is so he's so
kind and polite but i used to be like
damn and every and sterling he's not
pretentious like he just comes in he has
on jeans and a t-shirt so he's not
coming in like
trying to do anything
i have on like 20 year old like
dingy swamps
a baseball cap like it's
it's rough just walking through like
where's waldo like i'm like i think
that's regina but i'm not sure
oh jesus it's true who in your family
are you most excited
to see this film or in your family who
you're like please don't watch this film
you're going to be maybe a little upset
uh mama
look
mom i'm excited for her to see
everything that i do um because she's
she's a big fan she loves the church she
loves god and i'm wondering if she
thinks that this would be off limits or
not so i'm curious to see how she
responds to it after she takes it in
hopefully she'll be all right i love you
mama i'm not trying to disrespect nobody
yeah that's regina
um uh
well uh but my parents are in heaven but
if they had been here i would have loved
for them to see it but but you know my
my
my brother yeah my brother my brother
john specifically yeah
and then the other two sinful ones
[Laughter]
so odie and walter so yeah my brothers
yeah and lastly girls trip two
what is the t what is
i know you know it's it's it's more
scheduling and they haven't finished
writing it yet to be honest okay
okay well we ready okay okay okay
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you guys thank you so much have a
good one
you too